hey everybody I'm Jillian I'm Dave
welcome to the show so today we're going
to check out four great big stories and
they're all about adventure we're going
to travel through the tops of mountains
to the bottoms of lakes and inside the
huge heart the first person we're going
to meet is in the mountains and she is
getting very high real high super high
when you highlight often you really
learn to train your fear like a muscle
sometimes the height isn't the scariest
part
sometimes it's the exposure which is how
much space you can perceive around you
[Music]
my name is safe sticky and I'm a
professional slackliner so slacklining
is the umbrella term for all the
different facets of walking on a flat
woven band one of these facets is
highlining
which is walking a slackline high off
the ground one of the best ways to train
for highlining is setting up slack lines
over water when the current is passing
underneath you you automatically start
to follow that same direction and it's
almost like you're not in control of
your body and that's great practice for
highlining because in highlining when
you're dealing with all the fear and
adrenaline oftentimes it feels like
you're not in control of your own body
either
[Music]
hominy is a town in the Alps of France
and it's one of the places that really
drives me in highlighting what's
different about highlighting in the Alps
is that the whole experience is more
intense being that high off the ground
you look at the valley below and the
houses are just tiny specks they look
like toys it's unbelievable
one of the high lines that I walked
recently in Xiamen II was on ideas
immediate op it was a totally clear blue
sky and we were surrounded by peaks but
during the process of breaking the
clouds started to roll in it was like an
acid trip walking the line I was out
there in space and exposure trying to
balance and the line was swinging
beneath me meanwhile these huge white
clouds were passing and the line would
disappear the anchor would disappear and
then it would reappear and there was no
way to control it I just had to hang on
yeah the beauty of the mountains is
awesome and yet it is a landscape that
demands focus and respect Alpine
highlighting is the purest form of the
sport I can think of
[Music]
our next story takes us on a literal
treasure hunt what will we find this guy
Forrest has hidden a million dollars of
treasure somewhere in the Rocky
Mountains yeah and no one's been able to
discover it yet so let's go see what we
can find in 2010 this man Forrest Fenn
hid a chest filled with gold and rare
artifacts somewhere in the Rocky
Mountains the search for this
million-dollar treasure has obsessed
thousands of seekers worldwide and the
trail starts with this poem which Ben
wrote it contains nine clues that point
to the treasures location here someplace
where we roll in as I have gone alone in
there and with my treasures Bowl I can
keep my secret where and hen of riches
new and old and motivation for hiding
the treasure was to give hope to those
knocked down by the recession and to
inspire that took for the wild I found a
beautiful little Romanesque treasure
chest and I started filling it up with
with gold coins and gold nuggets in
about 280 rubies there are two salon
sapphires there eight emeralds a bunch
of diamond but mostly gold I don't know
what it's worth and I don't even want to
think about that you're not going to be
disappointed if you find that treasure
chest
[Applause]
I'm Cynthia Meacham's and I am a
full-time treasure hunter I have been
looking for friends treasure now for a
little over three and a half years
I hid the treasure chest more than 8.2
five miles north of Santa Fe in the
Rocky Mountains someplace nobody knows
but me
[Music]
the poem that you have to solve first
always said you have to find where warm
waters halt and to me this is where our
warm waters halt that's where I think
that we need to find the treasure chest
the thrill of this chase for Fenn's
treasure has led many to leave the
safety of known trails and well-beaten
past the mountains are very unforgiving
it's extremely important that you know
what you're doing and you know where
you're going you can end up in big
trouble really quickly there's even one
hiker that's been lost looking for the
treasure and he hasn't been found yet to
send knowledge the treasure remains a
hidden mystery but the real reward
should come from the right
I was positive this was our warm water
salt and unfortunately I just I don't
think that this is going to be the spot
it doesn't matter what state you
treasure hunt in you're going to have
beautiful scenery like this and it
doesn't matter if you find the treasure
chest or not this is finding the
treasure right here so hear me all and
listen good your effort will be worth
the cold if you are a brave and in the
would I give you title to the gold so
Dave yes Gillian's do you believe in the
Loch Ness monster I don't know if I do
but I feel like you might know someone
who does I do and he's been looking for
25 years his name is Steve let's go meet
him
the Loch Ness monster is one of our most
enduring myths people have sought its
secrets for over 1,500 years but only
one man has devoted his entire life to
learning the truth alone a dam by the
lock and no he's not a wacko
it's just his thing my name is Steve
Felton and for the last 25 years I've
been a full-time hunter of the Loch Ness
monster
I first came to lock this another 7 year
old boy and found this set of caravans
with this gang of grown men hunting for
monsters in Loch Ness and I thought
that's amazing that would be the life
for me I'd love to do that
and so he did 25 years ago he quit his
job sold his house bought this van and
pursued his passion he now holds the
Guinness record for the longest
continuous search at Mach ness in all my
time here I've only seen one possible
sighting of something all you saw was a
spray of water off of the back of
something bop bop-bop-bop like a torpedo
going shooting through to this day that
remains a mystery to me as to what that
was
that was in the first year of being here
and I fought right this job can be
really easy
that's one sighting 25 years later I'm
still sat here waiting for that second
sighting some people think it's giant
eels some people think there's a ripping
time others believe there's a spaceship
on the bottom of the last it's more
likely to turn out to be big catfish
than a spaceship on the bottom of the
law
the reason I sit here and I try and
solve this mystery is because that's
what makes my heart sing people say is
it lifestyle or is it the mystery it's
both my life contains freedom adventure
unpredictability and the chance of one
of the world's greatest discovery should
I ever happen to find Messi it's a dream
come true that little seven-year-old boy
you could see what became of him he
wouldn't believe in luck for a next
story we're going to go on life's
greatest adventure which is love the
journey of the heart you guys this one
makes me cry it's a tearjerker let's go
meet Lila an astounding Mississippi
first up a bit this Louie's devil shall
we get it we met I had an eye you know
and that must have been love at first
sight
[Music]
this is Charles Lala
Evan all right here we go he and his
wife Louise lived in this house in
Starkville Mississippi we were married
59 years and 11 months and we were one
months after this year we almost make
fix it after she died while I created a
unique tribute to her I decided I'll do
this in memory of her and we call this
Lala and Louise's play it is personal
memorial to Louise made up of thousands
of photos this is it this is it
everywhere we went we took pictures you
know you stand over there now to make a
good one you stand over here that'll
make a good one hold it hold it hold it
click we had talked about it before she
passed that one day we want to build a
museum to put these pictures in we
didn't get a chance to do that but the
idea never left my mind in fact I'm
going to do it anyway
this was 1968 we were going dancing
somewhere back in those days dancing
with a big thing when I first met my
wife she couldn't dance and she just got
tired of that [ __ ] that you won't teach
me how to do that and after I told her
we were such a smooth couple you know we
didn't we didn't miss a beat man this is
my 33 collection bow tops look at a
photo top Smith Ohio Players 45 series
oh man yeah
so did we yes sir yes we did this right
here our last dance
I'll never forget it it was in July and
I took her spin the round dipped it for
the last time brought it back up put one
of them over you know the following
Friday is when she had a massive heart
attack and she wasn't responding you
know all of a sudden she looked up at me
and said I love you and that was it
okay change another god we had such a
beautiful life I got so much to remember
and I'm just living a beautiful memory
thank you everybody for joining us today
as we went on a viewing adventure don't
forget to click the horse to subscribe
to great big stories and leave us your
comments below we want to hear from you
can't wait to see you next time see you
next time bye